hello friends I'm Alan welcome my
channel I thought that I would make a
very quick video at the end of my
workday today because somebody done made
a thread on a forum and I feel like this
is gonna keep coming up so sometimes
it's easier to just leave this thing
here for people to in theory some of
them to just find before they come and
comment on something else or for me to
link to people who comment on other
things about what I'm talking about
terrible intro I'm not reviewing so Punk
2077 never was haven't reviewed a game
on this channel since July 2018 which
was no man Sky's next update I have
reviewed games more recently on inside
gaming absolutely none this year so yeah
I'm not reviewing cyberpunk 2077 for
those wondering how this whole came
about basically somebody made a thread
about how I got this chair and unboxed
it and was like how could we ever trust
this person who calls themselves a game
critic thing I've never called myself by
the way even if I am a human who has a
lot of opinions on video games I don't
call myself that
to review cyberpunk when they get free
stuff from CD Projekt RED that cost this
much money so basically just the answer
is I'm absolutely not reviewing it and
in every video that I have put up of
cyberpunk gameplay this year I have
repeatedly said I'm super biased where
it's concerned I am both very excited
about the game and I'm owning that in a
way that I didn't let myself when I
walked in more traditional games media
they just didn't let myself get super
hyped about stuff which is like kind of
a downside of working in that field I
was always trying to stay measured so
that I wouldn't get carried away and
hype as of course is part of the
journalists job now I'm just learning
that I'm very excited about cyberpunk
and yes they have sent me some free
stuff super biased again I will say it
in every single video I have in every
single video so it's not like I'm hiding
that I'm literally saying it from the
jump but then on the tail end of this I
just wanted to bring this up super
quickly I think people have
misconceptions we're sending people free
stuff is concerned this is something
that I think happens a lot more to
youtubers than it does to traditional
media outlets for example when I works
at IGN the policy was that you could not
accept gifts so for a certain value they
would immediately be confiscated and
given to IGN
so for example oculus sent me an oculus
while I was working in IGN it became
IGN's property I really wanted that
[ __ ] oculus
it was a bummer but because it was over
a certain value it didn't matter it
became a gions property inherently being
sent to that building under my name the
same applied for consoles for Xboxes
Playstations anything that is usefully
expensive basically I think the cap was
$50 but I actually don't remember
exactly and the outlet that I work for
an Australia before that had a similar
policy we weren't allowed to accept
anything at all unless we kept it like
on our desk at work basically so
basically just wanted to explain that a
little bit further for some of the
misconceptions I'm reading but yes the
core of this video is I'm absolutely not
reviewing so I would Punk 2077 yeah
right you shouldn't trust me
I'm biased is help I'm very excited
again
literally never going to lie have said
critical things about my experience
playing the game you are totally welcome
to just stop watching anything that I do
in regards to cyberpunk which is largely
mean just talking about it very
excitedly but in every single video I
will continue to say super bias where
this game is concerned there is no
secret here alright that's it just
wanted to have this made so that I don't
have to keep responding to people about
it or and maybe it'll like fix some of
the confusion people are having
regarding this stuff not a game review
or any more fan not a game reviewer any
more and that is it for me today
everyone also a note I'm actually gonna
be on Twitch gaming's live show tomorrow
morning talking about my time playing
cyberpunk let me find the details yeah
it'll be on twitch.tv slash twitch
gaming and I will be on probably like
11:20 but the show actually starts at
11:00 a.m. and it's basically like part
of her I guess a new show that that
twitch has started that it's sort of a
like weekly wrapup of games and gaming
news so check that out if you like if
not also cool all right I will see you
guys next time like